hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and in today's video I'm going to talk
about stopping volume you know I did a
presentation the other day it's up there
on YouTube it's called discover new
trading strategies with order flow and
one of the things that I talked about in
it was
um stopping volume and what stopping
volume is is basically volume that
appears in the order flow
that essentially stops moves now it
doesn't mean it stops it for the rest of
the day or the rest of the week it stops
it right now and often causes a reversal
and
one of the easiest ways to see it is by
looking at points of control now
you know nowadays you know in in the
year 2022 that we're in the markets are
much more volatile than they were you
know 10 years ago five years ago and
honestly you used to be able to see it a
lot more in the past because you know
markets just didn't have this this
volatility that we're seeing nowadays
and one of the easiest ways to see
stopping volumes is what I call a point
of control on the extreme
and in the bonds you know you still tend
to see it in more of the you know the
the more what do you want to call it you
know the interest rate markets and
commodity market so this is a uh this is
the ZB the 30-year Bond point of control
on the extreme very visual very easy to
see
as a Trader right it's simply a red bar
with the point of control at the very
top or a green bar with point of control
at the very bottom now when I say
stopping volume being a reversal right
if you have point of control at the top
of a green bar that's not reversing
anything right the market is still
moving higher but what you when you have
the red bar the point of control at the
top obviously the price action is
starting to go down so here we have you
know the market rallied from you know 14
all the way up to 01. hit some volume up
here up here at 01
and in the bar the market turned around
and started selling off and sold off
over the next two bars you know a good
uh eight nine ticks right then we went
back up we sort of hit that level
rotated around for a couple bars poked
up a little bit higher and it's more or
less you know just rotating around that
level at Double O and o1 and then a
double o
we put in some and finally you know the
buyer stepped in and put in a base here
right they said okay we're going to
support it here at 01 you got the point
of control on the bottom
then the market kept rallying right so
how do you trade this well when you see
it right wait for the bar to close
because obviously you know if you see it
early in a bar and you get all excited
you know Traders love to get excited and
that's one of the problems that many
Traders have is they get excited too
fast and It ultimately what they end up
doing is
getting into a trade early that they
really should just stay out of
so wait for the bar to close at a bare
minimum
and you know let it print let that bar
finish and once it does
watch the next part is it continuing in
that direction if it is then you get
short right if it's a short signal or
you get long if it's a long signal
because you know time and time again
water flow changes in a bar I mean even
on honest on a one minute you know this
is a four range bar but even on you know
a one minute bar there's times where in
the first five ten seconds very bullish
and people think oh I got to get in you
know I'll get in early make a few extra
Pips and then ultimately things change
in the bar and what was looking bullish
turns out to be bearish and the Market's
reverse and all of a sudden you're stuck
you know
holding the bag so to speak now you know
when I talk about stopping volume it
doesn't necessarily have to be points of
control on the extreme you know nowadays
in the S PS it's very rare that you that
you see one and you know what I like to
look for is them appearing you know sort
of you know near swing highs or swing
lows you know points of control
somewhere up near the top for you know
reversals for shorts or somewhere near
the bottom uh for bullish ones and you
know on the order flows Trader software
we actually have this thing that's
called the
um Prominent Point of controls right
which are pointed controls that matter
right remember every bar has a point of
control right so you see Point control
one two three Prominent Point of control
level one level two level three uh for
now I just got level one turned on in
level two and I I love finding them you
know coming in at swing highs and swing
lows because their their potential
Market turning points okay so here's a
swing low right I got a bullish
Prominent Point of control Market just
going sideways a little bit and it did
pull back a little bit further then you
got a nice little rally there
all right here's a nice bearish one and
you know the reason I'm looking at the
top two point controls as opposed to a
point of control on the extreme is
because due to the volatility now that
exists in the market
it's you're getting the wider bars and
you're just not going to get them you
know on a bar that that trades you know
10 15 ticks it's very rare that you're
going to get
the point of control on the extreme just
because there's so much other activity
going on you know price Discovery
um you know Algos in the e-minis you
know in these Equity markets they're
really you know up ticket that it won't
necessarily appear right up there and
like I said wait for the bar to close
and wait for the next bar to confirm so
for example this is a Prominent Point of
control because at this time right the
market was going up or if you're looking
at it like right here and thinking okay
I got a bearish Prominent Point of
control here you know I got some
stopping volume I got these two point
controls lined up you know that that's
potentially bearish in the sense that
this bar is a red bar now however I mean
you guys still analyze what's happening
in the market right yeah it's a red bar
but barely right the market actually
traded down and closed you know within
the tick of its high you got these two
pointed controls lined up
side by side here which
you know is important because you got
two here you got two here now you got
another two here
so you know the sort of migrating higher
you know this one isn't one you know I
it's confusing you gotta wait for the
bar to close and then wait for the next
bar to form okay if it starts trading
lower yeah potentially you know that's
my opportunity to get short but in the
next bar the very next bar what happens
it doesn't go any lower it holds the low
of this bar and actually trades higher
actually trades above the high so this
bearish point of control is it's no
longer bearish right the whole reason
for it being bearish is gone already
right because we traded up through it
it's violated
then the market goes a little bit higher
comes in goes sideways goes back up now
you got another bearish Prominent Point
of control you got some stopping volume
appearing up here
now if you were to you know just go back
here right you got this one coming up
okay Point control is not lined up like
they were earlier it's a little bit
higher which is nice this bar it's I
mean the point of controls on this bar
is coming in higher than any of the
previous bars which is also nice to see
because you know it's just sort of
poking up you know it's just sort of
like the market is coming up sticking it
set up out of its hole taking a look
around you know I want to go higher you
know Traders are trading back and forth
you know there's some volume coming in
that's the heaviest volume in the bar
and we'll see what happens well the
market reverses down it closes down near
our low okay so it's bearish right this
one this bar is looking Much More
bearish Than This Bar earlier right this
bar we closed just right up here near
our high even though it's a red candle
now here we got a red candle but the
difference we're closing near our low of
the bar obviously we got that big wick
up here
so what do you think is more bearish
this bar here or this bar obviously this
bar right because the price action is
telling you
that selling is coming in late in the
bar that's why I always say you know
wait for the bars to close because you
know while this bar early may have you
know Big Red Bar down here is looking
bearish oh I gotta get in now well if
you got it now by the time the bar
closed you're like this doesn't look as
good as it did before whereas this bar
here early in the bar you know it's
greens the green candles trading higher
but It reversed and started trading down
and it closed down it looks bearish
right so okay maybe you're still
confused wait for the next bar take it
on a bar by bar basis next bar obviously
big bar down now do you have to wait for
this bar to close to be confirmed that
yeah you know what this Market's going
down
yeah I mean you can but you don't need
to I like to just let the market start
ticking down you know taking out the low
of the bar that I think is a bearish bar
just to confirm that yeah price is
moving that's where I'd be looking to
get short where do you place your stop
just right above the high of this bar
because the point of control is up near
the top and if I'm thinking of stopping
volume
if the Market's going to get past any
heavy volume up here I don't want to be
short anymore because it's gotten
through that volume just like here if I
was short off of this bar say you know
what I gotta get short because you know
it looks bearish and it gets short pull
the trigger immediately okay where's my
stop it's just right up here right right
above the high of the bar
this the high of the bar with the
bearish point of control what I consider
stopping volumes because if it trades
back up above 64 and a half here
that my whole
idea of being short is violated right I
don't want to be short anymore
so that's the differences between this
one and this one right I mean it's again
you know sometimes Traders like to make
things more difficult you know let the
market show you it's let it tip its hand
let it show you the direction it wants
to trade in and as soon as it does
that's the time you pull the trigger you
don't need to wait for this bar to close
you know a lot of Traders you know that
trade with
um you know other forms of analysis
technical analysis you know Head and
Shoulders Etc they're always waiting for
confirmation
that's fine but you're also giving up
tips it's as long as this Market just
starts showing its hand you know sort of
leaning in a direction it's giving you
all the signs that yeah this is the
direction we're going in that's when you
want to take advantage of it okay so you
know hopefully you understand what
stopping volume is a bit better you know
and how to take advantage of it you know
another way I like to use it really
quick
um is I like to use it as levels where
the market could come back
okay so you know this is a point of
control at the extreme it's not a
Prominent Point of control but
nevertheless it's just a normal point of
control that's appearing at the bottom
of a green bar so I know that there's
some volume down here heavy volume
okay I like to just trade these for you
know Marcus if they come back
that's a potential buying a place to buy
it right imagine it came right back to
67 or
and then just shot straight up it's like
those carnival games you know where you
you gotta hit the the lever and it
shoots the thing up
um that's what it looks like it just
came right down to that price got
through it by one tick and then shot up
from 67 all the way up to what is that
73 and three quarters
in in the same bar
now they don't always you know look as
nice and neat as that but you know you
don't need to be right every single time
right you're just risking two or three
ticks to you know take advantage of it
um let's just see if there's anything
else here this was today
um really you know here's two
bearish pound reporting controls
stopping volume coming in in this these
two bars you can just see how the market
reacted nicely right off of that just
sold off very quick from you know 87 and
a half all the way down to you know
where's it this one is this is like 81.
yeah but call it 82 because this is 82
right here for 87 down to 82 a quick
five points in five minutes so anyway
guys I'll end it there for today
hopefully you got to your your creative
juices flowing on what to look for with
uh pointed controls so thanks everyone
be sure to like And subscribe the
channel
and be ready for the next video bye-bye